often people roll out of an addiction
and I don't say they trade addictions
but they lean into healthier behaviors
and it sounds like your healthier
Behavior was hey let's let's get on a
path to help us get control back yes
you're not gambling anymore no totally
clean yes
when you're talking about it
your body folds up with shame and guilt
and today you walk off that stage and
you're gonna leave that crap right there
right yes sir you're done with it yes
sir you're announcing to everybody your
sobriety and we're proud of you amen I
don't want you carrying that stuff
around I could see it on you today you
set it down when you walk off that stage
Andrew and Courtney at Madisonville
Kentucky 62 thousand dollars paid off in
22 months making 85 to 95 count it down
let's hear a debt free scream three two
one we're here to get free